en 1864 la guerre de sécession se
termine et se dirige vers une victoire
des yankees du nord contre les
confédérés cette grande guerre civile
fera plus de six cent mille morts il va
traumatiser à jamais les états unis le
président abraham lincoln est le grand
vainqueur et il se prépare être
l'artisan de la paix et de la
réconciliation avec le sud auxquels il a
imposé la fin d' esclavage il lui faut
un vice président qui sera amadouer les
sudistes
sans les humilier davantage qu'il
choisit ce sénateur démocrate du
tennessee
andrew johnson qu'il l'a bien servi
pendant la guerre et qui comme le montre
le film tennessee johnson de 1942 est
resté fidèle à l'union dès le début
quitte à passer pour un traître chez ses
compatriotes
né dans une famille très pauvre un dow
johnson devient artisan tailleur et
gravit les échelons de la politique du
tennessee
les sièges au sénat à washington alors
que la tension monte entre les états du
nord abolitionnistes et le sud
esclavagiste lui-même johnson est un
propriétaire d'esclaves ils l'ont eu au
moins 14 esclaves en sa possession
c'est vraiment un vice-président qu'on a
choisi dans un contexte une élection qui
se déroulait en temps de guerre et une
élection qui à l'origine sans ce présage
est très mal pour les hinton qui était
lui-même convaincu qu'il allait perdre
sa réélection et donc il fait ce choix
audacieux finalement 2 confie la place
de vice président aux démocrates un gris
johnson on rappelle que layton lui est
un républicain pour mettre de l'avant ce
qu'on a pris un ticket d'unité nationale
finalement
lincoln est réélu en 1864 son
vice-président est assermenté le 4 mars
un mois plus tard lincoln est assassiné
au théâtre ford de washington par
l'acteur john wilkes booth
le lendemain un joe johnson devient
président
la réconciliation du nord avec le sud
souhaité par abraham lincoln ne se
produira pas au contraire johnson
pardonne les rebelles du sud et même
s'il est contre l' esclavage
il fera tout pour s'opposer aux lois du
congrès qui veut faire appliquer dans le
sud des mesures favorables aux
afro-américains et il est très très
favorable aux états du sud alors que les
républicains qui dominent alors très
majoritairement le congrès puisque les
états du sud n'ont pas encore été
réintégré au capitole elle voudrait bon
qu'on soit plus sévère à propos du sud
alors que johnson voudrait finalement
qu'on cesse l'occupation assez
rapidement il appose son veto
systématique aux lois votées par le
congrès sur les conditions d'un retour
des états du sud au sein de l'union
le véto trop c'est celui sur la loi des
droits civiques de 1866 qui garantit la
pleine citoyenneté aux anciens esclaves
johnson trouvait qu'elle était
discriminatoire en faveur des noirs et
contre les blancs c'est la rupture
totale avec le congrès républicain qui
veut se débarrasser de ce président
combes rend intolérants et trop imbu de
lui même
johnson limoges edwin stanton son
secrétaire à la guerre non mais par
lingen ce qui sert de prétexte à une
procédure de destitution par la chambre
des représentants
c'est la première fois dans l'histoire
du pays
deux films de 1942 montre le dernier
vote celui du sénat sur la culpabilité
du président il est acquitté par une
voix de majorité
chris johnson a complété son mandat
mais on ne va pas le laisser se
représenter les états du sud feront tout
pour brimer les droits civiques des
noirs dans les années suivantes
les présidents qui lui succéderont vont
continuer dans le laisser faire donc
c'est toute cette ligne est peut-être de
prix
dans de grandes erreurs qui ont été
toujours pas voulu poursuit finalement
le travail amorcé par les initie ses
plus proches conseillers ça se répercute
encore jusqu'à nos jours tout est exact
on notera évidemment des traces cette
irrigation mille de ces tensions
raciales récurrentes qui viennent
ponctuellement marqué l'actuel tenir
tout comme james buchanan hindous
johnson se situe en bas de la liste des
présidents américains même s'il reste un
héros dans son état le tennessee
[Musique]